Absolutely,
yeah,
there,
there's definitely something there is,
you know,
especially if you're,
you're in competitive sports or something like that where you just,
there's nothing you hate more than losing.
Right.
Good.
Because otherwise you won't work as hard.
Yeah.
But Jamie was talking about Kobe Bryan by what?
A psycho he was when he was training.
And they always say that about Michael Jordan.
And of course Mike Tyson was like that.
Coby said he learned it from Michael.
That's like what he passed on.
Kobe.
Pass it on to Lebron.
Yeah.
They went on the Olympic team together.
I heard Lebron spends one point $5 million a year on recovery because recovery
just recovery.
Just like Cryo therapy.
Massage.
A million and a half every year.
Yeah.
What a fucking stud here.
Dh.
Jesus Christ,
that guy.
So bad ass,
like maximizing everything.
It's like a perfect example of someone was Maxima Freak.
Genetics.
Powerful.
We'll intelligence.
But then on top of that,
maximizing everything,
built a school has a good sense of humor about himself.
Decent actor,
you know?
Yeah.
He was so funny in,
um,
uh,
was it?
No,
it wasn't wrecked.
The Amy Schumer movie,
trainwreck as half,
right?
Yeah.
Did you ever see that HBO show where they're sitting around with them?
You may never shop.
Yes.
Yeah.
He's fucking great in that.
And you get that insight.
It's like,
oh,
that's why you're so good.
You're fucking crazy.
Like he was talking about his son playing and he's talking about his mom and
like he's just his,
his drive and you know,
he doesn't,
he doesn't let anything go.
It's fascinating to me.
Yeah.
The people like that,
that are like extreme winters are there.
There's such a rare person,
you know,
and it's,
and it's rare that you could probably stand to be around that.
Yeah.
That's,
you know,
especially like your,
your kind of your,
your tech billionaires or stuff like that.
It's like,
after a while you'd be like,
you know,
I'm,
I'm going to go to the comedy store and,
and we're going to,
yeah.
Break each other's balls for awhile because this is weird,
man.
Right.
Like Steve Jobs,
like known by everyone as a extreme cont yeah,
right.
He was just a cut.
There's no way around it.
Yeah.
Brutal.
Do you remember that video?
There's a video.
It's a,
he's demonstrating a,
an apple product and he can't get this camera to work and he's pressing on these
buttons.
It doesn't work.
And he throws it at the engineer with this like pursed lips.
Aha.
He's like,
here,
you fix it.
See if you can get it to work.
Yeah.
Like just wants you fucking Loeser.
I'm in front of a million pay pal and he can't,
he can't lose his mind because it's like that Japanese ethic of the person who
loses their temper first loses no matter who's right or wrong.
I'm sure he loses his temper privately.
Oh,
without a doubt that guys.
Yeah,
there it is.
Watch this.
It's like you can't get it to work.
Like my camera's not turn it on.
What's that?
I did slide it in like,
Yo
angry.
Not turn it on.
What's asleep?
Okay,
please like this fucking,
he's fucking Turner.